[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight political campaigns are
all about how you finish you can be more
popular than your opponent is for months
even for years forever but if you're
less popular on Election Day you lose
it's all that matters it's a pretty
simple truth but it's easy to forget
Democrats may relearn it the hard way
very soon up until a few weeks ago
virtually every Democrat in America
considered the upcoming midterm
elections a certain win why well they
looked at the numbers the majority of
voters remain unsettled about Donald
Trump and if an election is a pure
referendum on him they believe the
Republicans would lose and lose big but
what if it's not all about Trump what if
there's another side to the equation
well there is and Democrats have just
reminded the country of that it all
began with Brett Kavanaugh Democrats had
plenty of ideological reasons to oppose
his nomination of the Supreme Court he'd
written hundreds and hundreds of
decisions but they barely mentioned any
of that instead in their frenzy to
oppose all that Trump endorses they
tarde Cavanaugh as a rapist they tried
to destroy his family and his life
evidence and due process were irrelevant
they told us again and again and if you
didn't agree with that they would scream
at you I believe her
I believe what she said it rings true to
me I believe her a large number of
Americans believe ur so those are not
ideological attacks those are Stalinist
attacks and they horrified normal people
across the country not just
right-wingers but people right in the
middle ever since Republicans have been
rising in the polls for the Democrats
the lesson of all this should been very
clear keep your crazies under control at
least until Election Day but they
wouldn't do that or maybe they couldn't
do that or maybe they no longer
recognized what crazy is in any case
they refused to make a rational case for
their own program and therefore
accelerated their own collapse Elizabeth
Warren led the way in this
in a bizarre self-inflicted injury that
she committed on national television
yesterday much the confusion of everyone
else Elizabeth Warren released a video
trying to show that she really is an
American Indian watch as the senator
anoints herself the head of the Mesa
movement now the president likes to call
my mom a liar what are the facts say you
absolutely have a Native American
ancestor in your pedigree I'm not
enrolled in a tribe and only tribes
determine tribal citizenship I
understand and respect that distinction
but my family history is my family
history I am not enrolled in a tribe
says a lady who's way whiter than you
are who thought that would work what
consultant came up with that even the
Cherokee Nation denounced Elizabeth
Warren and the media weren't that
impressed either actually it's not 1/10
it's not 100th one 1024 s does not allow
you to say you're a Cherokee seemed to
be that this was a way of getting the
Pocahontas thing out of the way put the
test out there now she can move forward
yeah and I don't think it does that for
her I don't think that the standard of
what was found in there is gonna be
satisfying the people best I can gather
according to your papers reporting she's
one one-thousandth something like I mean
I I think I might be is well some of the
press did defend Warren of course they
couldn't help themselves but their case
hardly helped the Democratic Party
because it was just too crazy
the New York Times informed us that
anyone who questions warned story her
ethnic appropriation of Indian culture
is you guessed it of course a racist
watch in terms of the Elizabeth Warren
the attack on Warren I believe that was
actually about white anxiety among
Donald Trump's face about who's white in
America yeah keep attacking people for
their skin color maybe that'll work just
like it did in 2016 two Democrats that
still seems like a good idea along with
a lot of other notions that ordinary
voters find scary and repugnant
self-described socialist advocating for
abolishing ice board
controls effectively eliminating the
barrier between US and other countries
and therefore eliminating our country
Maxine Waters cheering on the mob or is
Don Lemon over at CNN calls them people
who are angry in Arizona where Democrats
assumed they had an easy pickup of a
Senate seat their nominee
Kyrsten Sinema has been exposed as a
kind of lunatic who opposes all
immigration laws and apparently she says
finds the Taliban more bearable than her
fellow citizens in Arizona watch states
are the laboratories of democracy and in
my state Arizona is clearly the best lab
of democracy the past several years the
meth lab of democracy there's a way to
get votes Democrats could probably get
away with all of this and more if they
at least had an agenda that worked if
they could demonstrate our ideas bear
fruit that you might want to eat but
they can't do that not even close
California which they run completely is
failing sadly well drugs and human waste
fill the streets middle class people
leave because they can't afford homes
there Portland Oregon meanwhile one of
the prettiest cities in the country
suddenly looks like downtown Managua
with bandana clad thugs ruling the
streets meanwhile the city's impotent
mayor a wet liberal of course orders
police to stand down
[Applause]
it wasn't supposed to end this way
as you may know loathing of Trump was
supposed to be the glue that held all
the constituent parts of the Democratic
Party together instead it's destroying
the party and their efforts to fight
Trump they have become what they said
they hate it for example you've heard
over and over and over again that Trump
hates women he's a misogynist and yet
whatever Trump has said he never created
anything as repugnant as the rapper TI's
new video that shows a Melania
look-alike stripping in the Oval Office
watch this
[Music]
yep it's the party that cares about
women well still three weeks to go until
Election Day and Republicans in Congress
remain vulnerable in some cases very
vulnerable but at this pace Democrats
may fall far short of what they expected
what was their mistake as usual it was
revealing who they really are joining